ils sont venus des quatre coins de
l'alberta l'assemblée par un même
intérêt les énergies renouvelables
pendant deux semaines ces étudiants
apprennent comment installer des
panneaux solaires plusieurs d'entre eux
sont actuellement des travailleurs du
pétrole et du gaz
c'est le cas de mike ocha il voudrait
quitter son emploi dans le secteur du
gaz naturel pour travailler dans les
énergies renouvelables
à nadjaf voyais des side browser
pour lui le boom solaire est loin d'être
abstrait chaque semaine ils passent
devant cet immense centrale construite
au bord de l'autoroute transcanadienne
il intéresse au maintien malgré le fait
que les compagnies pétrolières ont
recommencé à embaucher
nombreux albertains veulent de la
stabilité ils sont fatigués des hauts et
des bas de l'industrie pétrolière
explique le formateur steinsel
plusieurs entreprises peinent d'ailleurs
à embaucher assez vite
producteur d'énergie renouvelable
recrutent dans le même bassin de
travailleurs que les énergies fossiles
confirme owen en corner en at il de
franck maury qui a débuté sa carrière
dans le pétrole en alberta la production
d'électricité solaire a été multipliée
par sept en seulement deux ans et
pourrait encore grandir par un facteur
de 10 d'ici 2025 et cette croissance est
en partie alimenté par les compagnies
pétrolières dont plusieurs ont promis de
devenir carboneutre d'ici 2050 comme les
opérations de pétrole et gaz en revient
maintenant un plan victor leurs
émissions et leur consommation
d'électricité augmente aussi
qui donc augmente aura la demande pour
crédit et compensation et en pétrole
plus cher signifie que les énergies
renouvelables sont plus compétitif que
jamais
une réalité économique qui contribue à
changer les mentalités dans une province
qui veut de plus en plus vendre une
image de championne non seulement du
pétrole mais de toutes les formes
d'énergie
ici françois julliard du canada edmonton